[Music]
how you doing sir yeah good good man is
super nice to have you back I think it
was about two years ago when you were
here first time yeah so we're gonna pick
it up where we left off so it is what is
going on what is going on what is coming
as my daughter said this morning
what's up yeah what is up what is up is
going down and what is up there it's
like a higher consciousness could we
toss a that I think we can I think the
true nature of ours is higher
consciousness as we call it high
consciousness I say it's just the nature
of our spirit to be everywhere in the
brain in the deepest of our physiology
capable to interact with our brain and
command our bodies into the subconscious
so much that we are able to make this up
conscious conscious and to become
capable of going into the brain into the
deepest is what I've shown since the
last time I did some new research not
some real good research neurological
research you Eve we're in they had 74
people talking about the deepest of the
brain the the moral of this story now to
begin with this if you go into the
deepest then you have passed all the
layers that means and not only 20% of
our brain we can use I say 100%
that's my moral that's my topic today
and you understand because you made this
switch I didn't understand who you were
really just a nice person in front of me
we talk and we go into the depth like
natural but I didn't know nothing about
your history only my daughter taught me
this morning yeah like a bloody respect
for what you did man thank you sir
becoming so big and a in society being
swallowed by society getting in there
and then
completely changed the paradigm within
yourself become the man you are fighting
and working on the good for Humanity
well I appreciate that I think that you
know our stories are very different but
if there's a similar thread it's that
it's that people look at the things that
I've done and they tend to hone in on
the athletic accomplishments in the same
way people look at your world records or
these these feats and stunts that you've
accomplished but truly it's a spiritual
journey my friend yes it's about raising
your consciousness exactly that's
ultimately the foundation beneath all of
this let me let me say something in this
room and so two years ago we came
together and we found out a we got
common ground and depth and I was into
the Vedas and sour Jersey and yeah in
the ancient tradition of Yogi's that's
that's what you are that's a this year
they wanted to give me a ward in India
for excellence in yoga I said man wait I
just wait a little until next year
because when we get evidence for
scientific evidence that we are able to
do much more than we think and we make
it common ground that is excellence in
yoga
yoga's unity unify and bringing it and
making it accessible for everybody
that's a that you did what you did for
example that's great
but what you do for Humanity right now
in bringing in a doubt that is
enlightening to to the soul itself and I
feel invigorated yeah I feel the soul I
think that there's a there's there's a
little bit of an arms race going on
right now because we are suffering from
a crisis of consciousness and people
like yourself are our beacons you're a
lighthouse of Hope a wash in a sea of
confused people and and a lot of moment'
behind systems that are working very
actively and diligently to destroy this
precious planet keep a sick and enslaved
exactly and so who is gonna win this
arms race yes
I call it a you know a battling and
tackling the real terrorists which is to
me depression bipolar anxiety fear
trauma PTSD all those things in the mind
we have no control over the mind and we
are manipulated I have to say this is
the way the power system is able to
manipulate and have people work for peer
for people earning two thousand times
more than somebody else it's the same
soul it doesn't make sense anymore
because all this industry and all okay I
say stop it and now all this epidemic
proportions of mental disorders and not
feeling good
how is that so I did study now because I
can talk like a hippie and say hey we
got to change the world revolution time
and oh love and flower and power you
need science though yes and so I want a
a day had me tested how if I would be
able to under a severe stress of say
cold coal distress and at stress on the
cells biology in the brain as in the air
as in the body and we have no control
over the stress and this stress was thus
within this experiment wherein they had
me shoving in into a brain scan and
seventy-five four people had formally
done the same experiment and they showed
dressed in perfusion vest where in cold
water streams in that the skin
temperatures just going down when the
cold water comes in and it goes up when
it is warm again skin temperature you
cannot do anything
with your mind it's just owned ow it's
going up going down this is stress
stress on our bodies on the cells
biology and we have no way to command to
stop it or to stand above it we have
none but this is our sympathetic nervous
system just regulating this on our
behalf
yes imagine wars and traumas and PTSD
and depression and all those things is
because of this stress getting in our
brains deregulating our hormonal balance
and thus we lose the good feeling and we
have no way to control that now 74%
showed all the same graphics and I
showed the same graphics when I did
nothing but the day day three I had to
show what the Iceman is capable of and I
really did not know what to do because I
don't know what to do right and then I
began to think back the way I was in
nature on Mount Everest in a wide art in
short tranquil nice swift no paranoia
under the eyes lost away and no goggles
on couldn't see anything
where was the hole no panic no fear no
paranoia even when your retina froze yes
yeah yes and so many more of those
situations I always had the confidence
and I felt this connection within the
body and I remembered that in Detroit
Michigan the morning I had to go in the
brain scan and show a different graphics
when cold water's coming in and warm
waters coming in and cold and warm and
cold and warm not affecting the skin
temperature by command by just thinking
is that possible and I thought yes of
course I had back through intuition I
had this feeling hey I'm just gonna do
it
so went to the University
they got me in the brain scan I always
say you give the best you get the best
and I did it I made my skin temperature
go one degree up and the cold was coming
in and it did not affect my skin
temperature like it was 35 minutes and
then they looked inside by the way the
cold water I had felt warm real warm to
you very warm and nice instead of cold
ice water coming in and I made it warm
and the professor had really a hard time
to put ice cubes in the in the in the
pump in the reservoir to make the water
cold because I was warming the water on
the water just by thought I was not able
to breathe deep or to contract the
muscles because you see blurred visions
images on the brain scan yeah so I read
about this study there was an article on
Smithsonian yeah where they kind of
described this and as I understand it
you were in this suit where they could
pump water like to cover your skin it
could be cold it could be warm and they
slid you into an MRI so they were
scanning everything as they were putting
this either cold or warm water into this
suit and then measuring how you were
reacting to this is that that is exactly
is that what went down so that that's
what we and a the cold represents stress
on the cells biology and you're normally
you have no way to deal with that stress
so you just let it go
it comes in cold and then warm cold warm
cold warm and we have no way to out
balance it or to transcend the elements
are working on the on the body not with
the mind but there I show to go and
transcend it transcend the impact on the
body and not only my body became warm
like really warm there in those areas
they looked up in the brain and what I
saw with the 74 people is that when
stress comes in and that's regular
stress can be anything emotional stress
will eat cold oxidative stress through
stress of daily life and all it all has
an effect on our being on our physiology
and normally we are not able just by
thinking to make that stress go away so
this is the way it works in the brain
when stress comes in and the prefrontal
cortex there is a lot of activation
that's your consciousness your direct
here-and-now consciousness which called
very activated insula which is activated
when in deep meditation when you feel
really relaxed a very inactive in active
at the moment when there is a stress
going on now that is what normal
normally works in the graphics and then
they looked in my brain and they saw
that the prefrontal cortex was
completely shut down and the insula was
really on not only so the while being
under stress I was in deep meditation
like the result of deep meditation is
insula activation it's like the for ik
and then they saw another thing and that
is actually yeah something innate but
unknown to science is the periaqueductal
gray hemisphere which is part of the
brainstem the deepest is between the
spine ganglia and the and the brain it's
where it all begins the very primitive
brain is its were created the opiate
opioids and the cannabinoids right
they in case of stress say depression or
danger or cold or impact then you need
opioids and cannabinoid to make the
unpleasant feeling and can go very
extreme in into pain and into feeling
bad about yourself and you don't feel
the authorial anymore at that moment we
have an innate capacity to down regulate
the imbalance and make it right again by
the the wrong feeling derivative allens
or hormone
becoming depressed or feeling bad
anxiety fear PTSD trauma anything in the
brain now we found the pathway to to
break the cycle of feeling bad the loop
and get a for ik hormones in
cannabinoids plus pain cycle we drop
through bringing in opioids and that is
they say we found compelling evidence of
the key components of the autonomic
processes autonomic is normally outside
of our well authority control and now we
have found him autonomic processes in
the brain were related to mood
regulation they say it's a
transformational technique that will
change mental healthcare that's what we
want if we go back to the beginning of
our conversation this we want to be
spiritual we want to have depth
spirituality is presence of your deeper
brain within your willful control
because everybody wants to be happy
strong and healthy that nobody knows and
but it is innate to feel that that way
and we are wrongly schooled in in the
primary school and then the college and
and and the universities and now we show
we actually that everybody has an innate
capacity and should not be law
on the way by cognitive cognitive like
the surface of the brain input of
information cognitive information and
doing nothing with the deeper part of
the brain you know what happens 25% more
blood flow goes to the surface of the
brain chronically logically the rest is
just surviving standby but not
developing and there is as our just sons
of just being and we talked about five
senses is the way we have learned to be
but there are three senses more like the
sixth sense the seventh and eighth
what's the 78 the seventh is the
proprioception is the air immune system
the immune system in the depth and we
have shown that already six years ago
first time in medical history to go into
the sympathetic and parasympathetic
nervous system activating the innate
immune system not only even into the
bone marrow which represents the
specific immune system the B cells
t-cells and direct and so on an intruder
coming in could be a virus bacteria yeah
this is the study that this study you're
talking about is the one where where you
and a cohort of individuals were
injected with E coli and E coli and it's
easy and for people that are new that
didn't listen to the first time order
aren't familiar with you like explain
that experiment because that bends a lot
of minds yes that it actually is so the
seventh neurological network is the
proprioception and there's this past
sixth sense
we got a absolute possible innate
control we just need to awaken that it
is a network inside and that makes us
able to activate the deepest of the
immune system when it's necessary we as
mammals in nature would die if we would
be like for days in a bed somewhere you
know we have this innate control but
because of our behavior we lost the
connection and this deep connection
I took on by E coli bacteria injected
and I showed for the first time to have
a control over the sympathetic the
autonomic nervous system are related to
the immune system which goes logically
very a deeper than normally considered
and a medical history a thought of this
is not possible to be done by humans but
this man is a he's the Iceman he does
strange things in nature yeah he is an
exception that confirms the rule and I
said no everybody is able to do this
this is natural and so I took this
cohort of people and within four days I
had them there we were walking in the
nature shorts in freezing temperatures
we danced our socks off on the top and
everybody was able to be there at minus
twenty seven centigrade which is really
freezing cold far below zero and and we
were dancing Dan I recognized these guys
are ready to take on the bacteria which
normally makes people very sick and they
will be able to battle it within a
quarter over hours something and four
days later they were in the hospital and
they did the breathing exercises and
they got their focus which is a
neurology is power if I'm able just by
mine willful and neurology thinking hey
I don't want to become cold while cold
is coming on the body and the body
becomes warm that's dealing with stress
just by thought so that power everybody
has but we never awoken that power which
is by the way network number eight the
entire reception into a receptive focus
and for the first time day so now in
Michigan that I was doing that they call
it the entire receptive focus and top
down which normally and they never had
seen that and now I tell but this is
natural and everybody has it it is only
through our schooling systems and the
way we
have our behavior that we do no longer
understand of the existence of deeper
mechanisms possibly within our control
it's gone
so but going back to the the experiment
on the a Ecola they all went into the
hospital they did their breathing use
their neurology their focus and within a
quarter of our hundred percent of these
guys after sixteen thousand and more
hundred and thirty-four people who done
the same experiment and all became sick
than to a sulli 12 people randomly
chosen of the 18 I trained in four days
they were exposed to the bacteria
injected and within a quarter of hour
all had control and with that we showed
that the specific immune system innate
immune system autonomic nervous system
can be controlled in contrary of what
was written medical history that means
and the inflammation in the body they
effectively suppress an inflammation is
the cause of any disease network number
seven well a couple observations here I
mean the first thing is the first
remarkable thing is that you train these
people for just four days right yes with
your techniques and that's all that was
required for them to combat this
endotoxin and fend it off yes
observation number two that we have the
ability the power the acumen to
manipulate and control our immune
response which is something that I think
you know conventional wisdom would say
is is something that is regulated
outside of conscious awareness or
control so that's a mind-blower and then
the third thing being that and this goes
back to the the MRI study with you in
this suit that through certain
techniques and and focus
and meditation practices that you could
cause or instigate your body to release
its own opioids endogenous opioids and
cannabinoids to what combat the pain
response or what exactly is that do the
pain and the feeling
so if auric fields come from
cannabinoids me coming from Amsterdam
you know yeah I can never know it today
yeah I don't even know that I knew that
we had endogenous cannabinoids within
our body it's a whole system yeah
endocannabinoid system regulates a whole
lot of organs within us all the Ceyda
cardio pulmonary area and
gastrointestinal area and bladder so
that's the whole torso and um we are
able to to regulate whatever is out of
balance therein and therefore we have
the opioids and there is a crisis on
opioids right now amen we got them to
our selves so no crisis anymore just for
that I'm here just to say that and we
got the proof so done right alright so
next podcast I did it we're over yes
you've made some some pretty bold claims
when it comes to how the body the body's
ability to combat disease everything
from and that's arthritis 2 diabetes
clinical depression anxiety bipolar and
and even cancer and I think a lot of
people when they hear especially when
they about cancer if you say very
careful and but now it has been proven
that there is a absolute relationship
between the immune system and cancer and
now I can say we and the immune system
are very able to activate the deepest of
the immune system and now it has been
proven in scientific papers that they
have a direct relationship so if you are
able to activate the
immune system in the depth that
absolutely has a positive effect on the
cancer cells on the DNA on the cell
division we are right now we just came
from Baltimore of fundraising and one of
the top researchers in the world Elissa
EPEL professor in San Francisco she is
leading a new study which we do on the
DNA and when the DNA becomes in tranquil
or wrong there and telomeres are being
affected then a cell division or the
wrong one cancer can happen now they see
that what we do is after 12 years this
is what they say after 12 years of DNA
research and we know by microscopes the
way they look like the DNA and the
telomeres and everything but we never
knew how to get there and to influence
it at will and now we got him so they
are into this study it's been endorsed
by the John W brick foundation mental
health care and 1.2 million I think in
San Francisco on this method
yes message that you just put out the
other day so you just basically
somebody's donating 1.2 million dollars
to this yeah because it's credible
because what we show is that we are able
to beat inflammation we are inflammation
is the cause for deregulation in the
body anyway and one of the deregulations
is cancer and I don't say directly now
we got a cure for cancer and he no but
we got more than probable cause to make
these studies and endorse it and show
that Nature has the answer and we have
to look into inside of our own inner
nature the neurology of the awareness
and our breathing we have become not
natural disconnected and therefore we
get all these problems if we go back we
will be able after millions of years of
development of our physiology
to down-regulate what is out of balance
back into balance in decor and have a
sense absolute sense of control I think
what's super interesting about you is
that what you're preaching and teaching
and the impact that you're having these
are very simple techniques you know
we're going to get into what they are
specifically in a minute but essentially
it's a call to return to our natural
state there's more primal lives to be
more connected to nature to connect with
the breath and to what it means to to
you know truly historically live in the
world in the most ancient sense of what
it means to be human
and that message is budding up against
the intellectualization of of science
and I think it's it's difficult to
digest for you know somebody who's in
the medical profession who's like listen
you know this guy's out here ranting and
raving and yeah he's some kind of crazy
outlier but like let's let's like you
know let's stick to the microscope
because here's what we have and we're
developing these drugs and this is truly
the path forward so these are two very
different approaches one that resides
very much in the mind and and yours
which is based on experience and things
like the heart and love and spiritual
connection which are ephemeral concepts
that a lot of people have a hard time
you know sort of wrapping their heads
around and embracing so this is this is
another one of the arms races that were
experiencing at the moment exactly
exactly and I say we have to get back to
they say the tribe feeling but people
who are lonely for example the white
blood cells get deteriorated and people
who are like in a tribe the family the
structure it's perfectly unbalanced
through nature through millions of years
we got disconnected and within affair
within the family and now all the world
is connected we are one tribe
you know the tribe before had no
hospitals had no pharmacies had no
industrialization or whatever they could
cope with any impact therefore we had to
elders and elders are the storytellers
they know about the experience what do
we do with the elders we put him in
elder homes and Pathak elite looking at
the television screen and nothing else
so a that's what they found out altar in
Pennsylvania receipt Oh when there was a
cardiovascular epidemic going on in
America in the 20s
except for that that region why was that
finally they became to know because
granddad lives with taking care of the
grandchildren and the people they meet
each other in the street and they talk
to each other and and they wish each
other well and touch each other oxytocin
and if their love gets into the body
into the biochemistry then the good
things happen neurologically igniting
the right hormones in the body this the
way we were built and what do we do now
we became individual we turns up the
elbow work I'm better than you I go
faster I want more and and going into
six hours is better than five cows and
and all that none sans is going and I
say what what we are unconditionally
already present within us is the ability
to become happy strong and healthy and
when we are able to bring back that not
natural knowledge which sans you don't
need two cars because you're already
happy you're with your family and the
way nature amended to be and there you
really become powerful now it is time to
use our neurology our consciousness to
tap into the deepest part of that part
of the brain which we lost contact
connection with
and we got it I can tell you we got him
we gonna tackle this real terrorist of
ours which is the same for everybody
depression bad feelings anxiety fear
PTSD trauma bipolar anything you cannot
come up with we found a way to tackle
that with phoric hormones and pain
killing hormones it's all there and we
got them inside and we are built to be
able to use it any time and with that we
get away from this fear-based thinking
to control but otherwise I don't have
the things to compensate my bad feeling
or my insecurities my fear-based
thinking it's gone and you live with
everybody and you wish well to everybody
nam sanema no because your energy is
right it emanates from the core instead
of from the brain that's very
threatening to the matrix yes you know I
mean it is it is an inside job it
requires you to look within and that's
very challenging to almost everybody who
has grown up in our modern Western
industrialized society where from day
one we're born and bred to you know
chase the the gold chain and you know
achieve and succeed and all these things
that you just said and that implicit
within that promise is of course
happiness and most people are chasing
that to their deathbed never quite
achieving that which they seek the most
which is a sense of fulfillment and
purpose excitement connection all of
these things all of the market forces
the economic systems the social systems
in which we are reared and and and
habitate today are pushing us away from
these very things that ultimately going
back all the way to the wisdom of the
Ancients are the true holders of this
promise of contentment and if we can
find a way to
have the wherewithal to invest in that
interior journey and engage with our
interior selves in that way we can
unlock this universe of potential that
we all are walking around with exactly
the power of the mind I call it
we are not bill - why should we have
100% brain when we only are able to
control 20% does it make sense
there sans is a macaws most of the blood
flow is always on the surface because of
our thinking ways the neurological
pathways we have learned to develop yes
so I've now found a way to get into the
deepest of the brain and with that
unlocking the possible power of the mind
to become just happy strong and healthy
not a circus act
I'm not into look at me what I can do
with a blahblah
no I just discover what innately we are
capacitated with everybody and there is
the unconditional love or yes the
unconditional love composed by the
guarantee to activate anything that
makes you happy
strong and healthy happiness is hormones
or four hormones the strength is the
metabolic processes in the in the cell
and we have proven that that we are able
to create more mitochondria or I mean
more ATP that doesn't matter how works
strength is there is energy and we are
able to guarantee flow therein we show
that and then the last one is the health
is the going into the deepest layers of
the immune system
it's all there it was always there and
it is connected to the brain and now we
found the pathways and and it's up for
awakening and with that comes the the
beginnings of the power of the mind for
everybody and there is the spiritual
journey because it is without thoughts
its feelings it's deep it's it's like
drugs
than your own we got this t-shirt I
could get high on your own supply
yeah and it's kind of nice but first let
us clean up clean up the place and get
into learning people to control and our
balance there depression bipolar anxiety
fear that it is no longer needed because
20% will become 100 percent control in
the brain so let's talk about what that
protocol is like how do we begin this
process of engaging the mind in a new
way
yes so there I came up with these things
because I didn't find it in no books so
I went into nature and in nature you
have no word it doesn't it's not written
when I'm in a white art but I feel
suddenly instead of the thought of a
paranoid because an anxiety and fear
because this is wider I mean in my short
and it's less than half the oxygen
present and nobody's around and I can't
see anything but white ice and rocks and
there I am four hours none feeling that
you are not in anxiety but okay you have
a feel confident nice and surprisingly
you're looking at yourself right it's
okay
this power is part of the power of the
mind which is able through intuition
orientation deeper than our normal
senses the sixth sense sixth sense not a
sick sense the sixth I gotcha
it's almost sick in their society
because there is no confidence
confidence is part of the sixth sense
it's a confidence comes when you have
control within your own brain past a
normal sense Oracle perception you got
images and feelings sick sounds is able
to go into the future because it has no
time-space perception it is different
it's there and you learned when it's
simply there not because your logic says
so know that because it is there and you
trust it then you feel confident and it
makes the right calculations and this is
what happened there I felt confident I
began to walk and my orientation GPS
anything is great working even in a
whiteout
three hours later I arrived in an
advanced base camp and was received by
Tibetan sand they must have seen a crazy
pilgrim a white man coming out of a
whiteout but they gave me tea and butter
when so where where and when was this
2007 on Everest oh this is your Everest
okay yeah yes out of the air I gotcha
okay so yeah that's when you you you
made it all the way up to the Death Zone
with basically just in shorts yes no
shirt right and then you had a foot
injury or something like that that
prevented you yeah
thing is I learned to to get into
different consciousness altogether by
going into nature because it wasn't in
the books would I try to find I am I
want to find the soul I want to find
enlightenment and the world has proven
to be a place where it is not and where
they ignore the soul's presence it's all
about profits and power and tension and
stress and dominating and exploiting and
polluting that that is what is going on
this big monster I think we are like
dragon slayers we go for the right tools
and then go ahead we go past our fear
and turn the wheel and and make
effective tools and bring it out to the
world that there is light in the world
that there is a soul in the world and
that we have a capacity to get rid of
this manipulative control
to find absolute a deeper sense of
control over ourselves because we own
really our own brain we are the owners
of our happiness strength and health
Dave Asprey asked me in this podcast
women what is enlightenment and please
tell it in what somebody else to and say
you didn't once said I said just be
happy strong and healthy and the rest is
[ __ ] the soul it's time for the soul
to be here and guaranteed and as I say
past any politics and bollocks and power
and this and culture and tradition and
religion the mother and Baghdad is the
same as in New York they just want a
guarantee for their children
happiness strength and health and now
because nobody was listening everybody
indulging into a religion and
differences instead of the equal side of
our all we just want to love our kids
wasn't dead so that's what we want and
that's what we need to stand up and say
go through science no speculation
anymore the time had you had to
speculate and to show you differences
with all the respect it only kills it
gives a bad quality of life no and a
health a depression and people earning
irrational amounts of money and the
other one not I see people homeless here
and I think a man it's still our so
until it is not solved that the
unconditional love which everybody
should owe like there are and owning
their own mind we have to keep on rich
and a a and stand up because [ __ ] the
past
what I all did and made our genetical
way of thinking in the through
epigenetics becomes genetics and now we
are stuck in the marsh and we got a
solve it yes that's what we do we
and up and we say no to war no to
disease no to depression we say yes to
happiness strength and health and we
prove it through science and that's
makes us man
yeah that's powerful we're in strange
times right now we are connected in ways
that we never have been historically but
that connection is digital it's its
temporal it's not real meanwhile we're
more divided than ever certainly
politically we have retreated to our
respective silos and tribes and we love
to shoot arrows at each other hmm and
you know signal to our respective tribe
members that were a member in good
standing well spending a lot of energy
distinguishing ourselves from the other
from them from the bad guy whoever that
is and this is reaching peak levels that
I've never seen in my lifetime and this
call to return to our natural state this
idea that the mother in New York and the
mother in Baghdad are truly one how do
we return back to that understanding and
that connection that can truly unify us
and supersede and heal this divide that
we're seeing right now that is that is
perhaps our biggest disease yes
heart disease in America's number one
killer obesity rates through the roof
depression the world's number one
disability PTSD diabetes cancer all of
these things are killing people at an
alarming rate while we're blindly
decimating the planet and with our hands
you know not on the steering wheel here
like this is a crisis of epic species
ending proportions like we can't [ __ ]
around here yes and we're running out of
time so the call to return to this
primal state of breath of connection
with each other and with nature as
simple and as basic as that sounds it's
still very threatening to the person who
is very much a consumer in this society
and program to behave in a certain way
you're asking them to do some very
simple things but it's interpreted as
almost a threat or a challenge to a way
of life that is so distinct from
everything that they they know and have
been taught mmm yes if you if you learn
a monkey to be a lion for a auditor it
doesn't behave like a monkey anymore
we have lost from our true nature and
with that with the capacities of our
true nature which is there to learn to
have a control over the full brain
I mean hundred percent because it's a
mind is the seed of the spirit of the
soul and the soul is the purpose and we
think it is just something randomly
chosen by religion the Catholics and the
Protestants and the Islamic and and
Zarathustra or whatever all these it's
just a difference they say is it
time-space a ego which doesn't have the
real ability or capacity to go into the
deeper part of the brain and experience
the unifying principle experience which
everybody has spirituality is equal to
everybody it has no label only the
differences where we came from the
time-space perception and ego related to
that those are the first baby steps we
learned how to conquer the power of the
mind so and then from there we learn
from time-space perception to go into
timelessness and everything the the
souls presence the soul now is confined
is imprisoned and what it shows is
disease and in all kinds of ways both
mental and physical it's because it's
not there and it only shows a that's why
you get sick you can't cover it up with
pills and medicines that kill their
messengers all the time not go to the
core how far because the power
money goes that way and and that's why
it's prolonged and keeping on and
because people are ignorant they lost
hope and the people if you really give
them the the alternative through I say
science then they are able to reactivate
that deep sense of Hope within them now
this society you come in and you say
yeah you gotta be the best in the world
and you got a position yourself become
this and that and that those are
sympathetic or asymptomatic tools you
get because they are everybody's in fear
and nobody knows that if you learn to
control the power of the mind you don't
need fear because the beautiful mind is
very able to go past the time-space or
what is happening in the future
resolving things from the past that's
why we are here and there is this soul
is inexplicable so presence that's why
we are alive and we get to know it and
to be that flower and then share it with
everybody
that's where we go so here I am talking
about it and say okay what what is the
real way okay I showed as the first
woman now again in the brain scans like
seven years ago I showed it the
autonomic nervous system innate immune
system endocrine system and hormonal
system all can be very deeply influenced
in four days with DC guys up the
mountain we danced our socks off well
being in extremes of nature because they
had the power of the mind present like
it is innately there for everybody but
we always are in this fear way comfort
zone behavior confined the way we have
learned and this is the way we need to
be know get out get into your true
nature and you don't need only hope over
there
you feel the power of your own mind
being able to deal with anything that is
out there
thus absence of fear is a logical thing
happening there so if you speak to
experienced meditators people have been
meditating for decades they will share
with you
experiences that they have had glimpses
of the beyond or a sense of expanded
consciousness and awareness and
connection and unity but for the most
part they will say these experiences are
few and far between and they're fleeting
the more you practice meditation the
more you can drop in with greater
facility and it becomes easier just like
anything that you practice but this is a
lifetime commitment and you're here
saying in four days I can do I can basic
now we do know how our within an hour
now give me an hour man
what is it like I know we talked about
this last time but the cold exposure and
these feats that you've done those are
the things that create the clickbait
titles and that's what people want to
talk about when they're interested and
but my impression and please correct me
if I'm wrong is that this is much more
about the breath work and the way that
the breath and these meditative
practices that you teach are portals or
ways of garnering control over these
traditionally thought uncontrollable
aspects of our awareness and our brain
lizard brain yes it is absolutely a rich
good good resume
nice yeah this is like a diving board I
can use it dive in now I made some
ourselves man oh and your neck soft rap
monologue yes I'm here to receive all
right oh right on
so the thing is a mindfulness for
example and seasoned practitioners of
mindfulness have been studied very well
a lot of research has been done like
hundreds and hundreds of papers and it
all shows that they are able to tap in
and deeper part of the brain which is
learning how to
decrease blood flow in the surface and
get a deeper and thus they become
activated those deeper part of the brain
and I feel like nice good and sometimes
they peek and they get even deeper and
that deepest part is the brainstem and
but that's rare and and now they the
professor's after looking in the brain
scans and looking in my brain and part
of my job but they found compelling
evidence that I possess brain activity
in the brain scan that's a joke the
brain is actually working yeah it is
it's not new online it's not new anymore
okay yeah
secondhand thing is they said the the
the part of the brain you made a robust
Lee activate we never see that in even
with seasoned practitioners in
mindfulness in different areas of the
brain different deeper areas of the
brain and especially under stress and
stress is the killer in society and
people are not able to tap into the
depth of the brain no more and now we
found a neurological pathway into the
deepest part of the brain and everybody
is able to learn to activate that and if
you just repetitiously go a couple of
times then it becomes stronger this
neurological pathway does the control
from the surface of the brain into the
deepest part of the brain and if you are
able to go actively into the deepest
part of the brain you are able to go in
all the ways in between that means all
the parts of the brain in hannover we
showed that the breathing technique is
making hundred-percent activity of the
of the brain suddenly the neurology the
electricity is activated everywhere in
the brain the it's a disco and the dance
is only beginning with a
when you are able to bring 25% a
dominant blood flow only in the surface
of the brain but now everywhere then the
activation of the powers related to
those parts of the brain are within our
control and and will how much of that
becomes under the aegis of conscious
control versus the activation then
setting in motion some kind of
autonomous processes that stimulate the
immune response in the best and most
healthy way like what is the awareness
level in terms of what's going on like
are you consciously like when you're in
the MRI and they're shooting the cold
water and you're you can't really do the
breath work but your I presume entering
into a meditative state like how much
are you is it is it like an effort based
thing or is it something that because of
your history of doing this that your
body just suddenly knows what to do like
I'm trying to understand like for
somebody who's listening to this who's
coming in brand new mm-hmm and doesn't
really understand we're talking about
here like break this down into little
chunks so people can really get a sense
of what the experience is like I thought
it was going to be very difficult in the
brain scan and to show active say
commanding from the brain the body
without moving without muscular activity
without just lying there
just a thought here comes the cold you
normally cannot do anything just my
thought related to the cold coming on
the body making the body colder and you
cannot do with your thoughts nothing and
I thought it was going to be very
difficult but no I learned that in
nature numerous kinds of situations for
example climbing without gear steep
rocks getting cramps and think it that
way or being in a cylinder full of ice
after an hour I got always this problem
with
kidneys they become too cold I can think
and warm up my body from the inside out
just by thinking or put your hand in
front of an infrared camera and within a
minute I can make it to 1012 degrees
going up just your hand yeah just my
hand and are you thinking that like are
you yeah just do it right and and so
there I was in the brain scan and I was
gonna give it my shot and what I did
because there's a terrible noise going
on they asked me to meditate and brain
scan they said right machine meditate on
that no I just began to just to have a
reference point of reference of my own
brain being there how what happened is I
felt no cold it became warm
I could even wander off with my thoughts
to the place and feel the warmth and
yeah it is not difficult to learn to
command the body top-down by your
thoughts and be the master over your own
physiology and with that bringing
happiness strength and health or
anything that is out of balance back
into balance that's the power of our
mind and I learned that in nature and I
say you don't need to climb Mount
Everest or go into ice water all those
things they are just a mirror that works
when you go into regular practice there
in the about the power of the mind the
neurological pathways we invest in
unhappiness we invest in the wrong
things
we don't want to be not happy but we're
not not being happy as a result of the
oxidative stress within us going through
the blood-brain barrier and
and taken away the balance between the
serotonin dopamine and become depressed
we don't know how to deal with that but
now we found top down we are to commend
us over our hormonal system when
anything is out of balance and once
again you don't need to go into the
extremes I did that I was the pioneer I
was the Scout and I say the Atome is
over there that's the way to tackle it
and here we make it simple on paper this
is the map by hacking map and this is
what you got to do instead of go frontal
into those enemy lines and losing a
whole lot of your life and time and and
miserable misery going into misery no
there's this space and if you just do
that you become in control of yourself
and can it be so easy it is simplified
its dare and if you invest into
happiness strength in health you a hard
to Commander data stop number one change
your paradigm what's what's interesting
is that because you have done all of
these crazy things swimming 66 meters
under the ice cap and climbing Everest
and the intention behind all of those is
to draw awareness to the power of the
human mind to overcome seemingly
insurmountable obstacles but the crazier
the feet the more easy it becomes for
people to just say you're a crazy
outlier that this is this time still a
crazy outlined by the way but what I
love about you is is every time that
argument comes up you deflect it and say
no this is like I do this to show what's
possible I can teach this this is
reckless replicable and put me in the
MRI let's do all these studies like you
become this guinea pig I mean we've only
talked about two of the many many
studies that you've done oh that time
again are showing things that previously
we thought to be impossible and you're
getting what's what's amazing is you've
created this groundswell movement I mean
I don't know five or six years ago
nobody
ever heard of you now you're you know
you're veering on becoming a household
name everybody knows that you are the
Iceman Cometh and you're teaching these
practices you've created this scalable
family business where you're now
teaching practitioners to teach you your
methods and this is creating this spider
web that is you know expanding
exponentially with every day and it's
really cool to see and you're getting
coverage not just in Vice but in medical
journals and you know people are paying
attention to what you're doing but what
I see between the lines is still a
reluctance of the traditional medical
community to really embrace or pay
attention to what you're doing there was
a rolling stone article that said
something along the lines of life look
he's done all this stuff and everyone's
verifying it and he's done he studies
and still he's kind of being ignored yes
right so exactly walk me through that
yes
ignorance ignorance is cold and that's
the basic of fear-based thinking
genetically already for hundreds and
possibly thousands of years it's the
power system the power system is still
on people just want more and more couple
of people and they never are satisfied
it's a it's a it's a mind so much in
control over others but not over
themselves and so if they you know
people in power are not necessarily more
happy than somebody else it's just a
they they are they crazy outliers not me
I just want to be in nature I want to be
with my mother or father with my kids
and all together happy strong and
healthy I think and I'm a crazy outlier
like I'm crazy about my wife and my life
and a with that comes the whole family
and I'm crazy about a [ __ ] bloody
crazy now and it will stay being crazy
with that those are the core values of
happiness strengthen how
and they are present so I think that's
just and what I see in the world a man
anybody can see it doesn't make sense
but it's there it's the power system
it's the mainframe it's the the the
matrix and I think we are let them now
but we are becoming bigger and bigger
we are beginning to settle into the hope
and trust and confidence of the people
that we actually are innately built to
be happy strong and healthy non
conditionally so that's why I go through
these signs and let us face hey you want
a battle inflammation and chronic pain
millions hundreds and millions are
suffering from autoimmune diseases and
and pain chronic pain and chronic
diseases and we found an answer easy
answer to tackle that considerably for
everybody so you better think twice
before you say no to this then another
thing as the mental disorders and the
feeling that the connection with your
own hormonal system and get high on your
own supply looks like hey this guy's
therapy from Amsterdam no I go through
neuroscience and show for the first time
in medical history that we have an
innate capacity to get neurological
control over our hormonal system and
become happy strong and healthy it's
there so mental disorders good by
inflammation causing diseases goodbye by
the way killer number one cardiovascular
related diseases a cold shower a day
keeps the doctor away how simple is it
contraction and dilatation of veins
three times the world is within us and
you train it if you just step a little
bit out of your comfort zone behavior
and take the cold shower after the hot
one then you tackle this cereal
the cardiovascular related disease makes
more casualties than any war nobody is
saying too much about it it's a silent
serial killer and we you are able to
tackle it through culture and you all
know a neurology I'm gonna take the cold
shower on regular basis and train
vascular fitness my vascular system and
thus it becomes flexible and not full of
as clear roses calcification which is
stopping the blood flow of going through
and you get a lot more energy just take
a cold shower physiologically what is
going on it's it's anti-inflammatory its
alkalizing your blood what else is
happening
it's absolutely yeah we did the studies
it's alkalizing the blood we suffer from
low si how do you call it a Cepheid
ation as a clarification yes
acidification acidification we suffer
from that that's where chronic chronic
acidosis as he does is that gets into
the lymphatic system and in due time it
comes back in this into the system
creating all these defects called
autoimmune diseases those are not my
words biochemical professors they say
and they said we have to congratulate
our colleagues in the university of
naming to have found her here what of
named Asian nation is a place is a city
okay is a city in the Netherlands and
there we found by putting getting the
under toxin inside we found a way to
battle with the cause of autoimmune
diseases which is inflammation Kalama
Tory Marcus cytokines and we bring them
down within a quarter of an hour and a
part of that is alkalizing the blood but
not only in the blood it also in the
lymphatic system and the lymphatic
system has a storage capacity the
garbage but you need to ante it and if
you don't then a desert
it comes back into the system after
years and years and nobody knows how it
really works and now we found that we
are able to tap into the lymphatic
system and cleanse the blood the the
liquids which of this is the breath work
versus the cold exposure it is is it the
combination of these two together like
how does that yes so the ice is is ice
is nice and worse if you learn how to
deal with that gradual colder exposure
but a cold shower does the trick
culture is really a cat or does it have
to be the way a cold shower is happening
right over here that's cold enough the
thermogenesis the vascular fitness this
stimulation begins and you will get more
energy because we got millions of
primitive muscles within the vascular
system and they all become strong so
they help the blood flow and the stress
of too much heartbeat it goes down like
20 minutes 24 hours a day that means a
lot of stress caused by too high a heart
rate is is gonna be down hey solution
and how simple just take the cold shower
they do not even think about it just do
it you get a lot more energy because all
these little muscles begin to help the
blood flow nutrients the minerals the
oxygen it brings it all to the cells and
in the cells we got the mitochondria
they get the right stuff in the right
speed and you get a lot of energy inside
and heart rate goes 2025 beats a minute
24 hours a day down and and there is
their piece and while you are in action
you become so much more in command of
this chemistry is when the Hat suddenly
the neurotransmitters of our thoughts
are able to command what is going on
inside that is number eight network
number eight the interception which I
showed that worth
thinking cold water comes skin
temperature I don't want it to go down
it didn't go down like two times thirty
five minutes cold warm cold or I just
stayed over there and completely flat
neutral yes even a one degree up so that
is how we have an ability to activate
our body to be protected skin
temperature or core temperature a skin
temperature both cool temperatures skin
temperature and the DNA now this what
they saw with in San Francisco they say
what this is is like hormetic stress
it's a positive stress that stimulates
it's not undergoing stress it's you go
to de-stress you are the one to activate
that stress you got it in control and
with that you activate a body to go to
his utmost functionality and there you
get a grip on and with that comes a
innate capacity to become happy strong
and healthy and our balance what is out
of out of balance and it's only if you
could design like what do we still need
to study and understand like if you
could design the ultimate study to
better understand the phenomenon that
you're speaking about what would that
look like like what do we need to do
next to really dive deeper into what
exactly is going on
I always say yeah the origin of what I
set out for my drive is because of this
soul this in explain all everybody is
talking about the soul nobody knows what
it got damn it what it is and I say this
time we're gonna bring this soul where
it belongs with all the core values it
belongs to and which is happiness
strength and health it's pure goodness
it's inside of us it's powerful it's
beautiful it's called love and this love
for life and everybody needs to come
back and because nobody was listening
everybody making war
God is loving it and they make war
between each other and they kill each
other and this and that you were wrong
we are right at hey no no no no the real
experience of spirituality is my aim I
call its the signs of the soul but
before that happens we need to show that
we are able to tackle seemingly
unsolvable matters like depression
bipolar inflammation chronic pain
anxiety fear PTSD trauma dose the real
terrorists let's tackle that first and
then get into the the right condition of
the DNA the deepest control of the
deepest of the brain and the deepest of
the physiology up till the lymphatic
when everything is being able willfully
to be reached and influenced in nothing
remains the soul is there and it can be
revealed it can reveal itself to you yes
people are scared of love though yes I
love the greatest power of the universe
yeah yeah yeah you want to be able to
with a thousand push-ups an enormous
Schwarzenegger kind of muscles and and
and know a whole lot and all that it's
it's quite a fear-based love the family
going back there and recognizing that
the beauty is all there and embrace it
and being able to be proud like a Maasai
warrior with with the Lions over there
and and little lambs over here and in
between like consciousness that
consciousness of course she should be
feared because it is the greatest power
of the universe but it's inside it's
tangible
we make it accessible and clear and
effective in the last two years since
since you were here I'm sure you've
worked with hundreds if not thousands of
people and now you have all these
instructors out there conducting
workshops and spreading this message and
work
with people what are some of the case
studies like transformations that people
have undergone Wow yeah you've worked
with yes we got so many thousands of
people
let me explain any people are out there
doing this right now
I think Millions I think millions and
they it's on but I think it's still the
whole world should know that there is a
non-dogmatic choice to be happy strong
and healthy evidence-based that is what
I want there is no Dogma around this
it's there I just say look look at this
you don't have to choose your happiness
strength to help but the ability to
become that is there so we got about
40,000 and more testimonials of people
who are a completely healed of their
disease a variety of diseases is as much
as diseases exist on this planet so it
gives absolutely cause to study and more
because I think this natural P we found
is unlimited it's only inaugurating a
new dimension through a different
paradigm into the power of our mind
within our control their soul itself is
knocking at our door so I was training
the Navy SEALs in a Pearl Harbor
I went and drove up there and there was
the barn I was thinking what I'm gonna
teach these guys their day - it was
because I always say things and they're
then just before the bar I got a mail of
a GP a practitioner a woman a doctor
giving me this mail and I read it out
loud or not out there just for myself
hello I'm Jan last year I jumped from a
third-story down course I had it with
the pain I woke up in the hospital my
brother told me about you and what you
do about he autonomous this and this and
that and now I just wake up every day
I'm happy and strong I'm confident yeah
I love you
GP Jan so and so then I went to the Navy
SEALs and I said that's win this [ __ ]
war this war on anxiety and bring real
peace there in because this is the war
really going on in all the world and the
Navy SEALs sleep deprivation and a lot
of stress a lot is they're gonna you
know doing the breathing day and
convincing them that they are in command
not the general of their own that they
are there and you have to sometimes just
shut shut shut up and get in become the
commander consciously and start with
your own beautiful mind and the power of
your mind and to yeah give some water to
you God and if flowers will come well
I'm sure they loved it because they're
already I mean that's a population if
they did they did very familiar with
discipline about always trying to you
know sort of control their reactions and
you know they have to be dialed in on
such a higher level than the average
human being they I would think that this
is like this is like the Advanced
Placement course in in how to you know
comport themselves under high stress
situations to function at their peak yes
and for that the the cold is a great
mirror because they're cold and
especially ice cold water is really
stressful on their cells biology and our
mind absolutely
so the the cult we use as a mirror to
develop more Skills of the mind and
refine them and develop a more and the
tune them better and
and that's it and then the coldest of no
use anymore but a cold shower where a
day keeps the doctor wait keeps on going
it's nice you it's you don't have to
take care of your body if you just go
into the culture because it will take
care of your body yeah
have you or any of these studies looked
at the impact of these techniques on
addiction yes there are a lot a lot of
people who fall in an abbess when they
are no longer as a addicted because
there's the substance is gone and the
reactions and actions caused by the
substance they are not being triggered
so the breathing helps greatly to fill
up that gap so yes and Bree like if you
had if somebody had to choose between
the breath work or the cold or you
probably don't even want to make that
decision oh I do I do I say the
breathing the way I learned about the
breathing is because of the cold because
what do you do when you go into gold
that's what you do you learn to go more
into profound breathing because then you
are able to change the chemistry which
is opposing the impact coming in for
that you need to change the chemistry is
done by deep breathing because we wear
all the clothes that's why we become
shallow in our breathing so I say to
people mind about this that you are
building up a deficit of the right
chemistry in your body just deep
breathing and conscious breathing during
the day
sometimes just it's all for free it's
out there and say you just do
consciously consciously means the
neurology it goes paired with the
chemistry you'll learn to really tune in
with the right chemistry in your body
making it alkaline to the level of the
lymphatic system the garbage is getting
out and cleansing it's all that and when
you simple so walk me through like it
in your life you're traveling all the
time do you set aside times during the
day to do a diligent practice or is this
something that you're just persistently
doing throughout the day like constantly
reminding yourself and bringing your
awareness back to the breath
automatically in this conversation
sometimes just take a deep breath in and
and that's it only when you let me talk
yes do that yes right and you know yeah
cold showers
love to take them and I'm not
exaggerating I'm not a you know going
into more more more Puritan kind of
training yogic training and abstinence
no I take it all I like my beer and
afternoon yeah to drink a nice little
beer hey I like it I like it I'm not a
as quitaque yogi or Adi I can be
yes kili kili but that's enough I don't
need to be a Jedi enjoy life no you do I
don't like it okay in the world you're a
man of it you're not you're not
anesthetic you're not gonna be living in
the caves in the Himalayas but when you
hear those stories of those Yogi's who
meditate for months on end or become
breatharians are those apocryphal do you
believe in that I trained a breatharian
spotter example yeah they have sometimes
a loss of energy and in the cult you
need energy so I trained them in the
cold and through the breath work and and
the neurology of their brain which is
also conditioned within their confines
they are able to gain a whole lot more
power over themselves over the energetic
metabolic processes in the on cell level
and all that yes they feel better
afternoons so Yogi's Yogi's should get
out of their caves and begin to teach
what they have found instead of being
their egoistic little shitty selves I'm
so beautiful I'm not only unnamed under
Tony
India right now is calling for me also
so it's like the the wise people do not
longer only come from the from the east
it's now here right here I look at one
and we we bring consciousness and we
bring love and understanding to the
people that makes us man and that makes
us universal that makes us eternal one
of the things I love about your your
story is that it's a very human story
it's almost this Joseph Campbell
Warriors path that you've been on that
was really birthed out of out of grief
and pain with the passing of your wife
oh yes that kind of led you into this
world of self-discovery and there's a
beautiful full circle aspect to this
because you're teaching people how to
overcome their depression and their
class and their pain and their suicidal
ideation because this is not lost which
you normally would suicide now no longer
because of this and exactly what you
point out is the full circle I began in
grief my wife jumped from an eight-story
down I was left alone with four kids no
money there are was I had to survive my
kids made me survive nature healed me
and then I began to see what was the
effective mode of at all and I was able
to transmit this to other people and
then I began and I had the chance to
show it within scientific laboratory
settings experiments research
I fully was on and now we the full
circle is if I would have known what I
know now I would have saved be able to
save my own wife so for those who are in
these situations where they are in full
despair of having their beloved in
depression bipolar in incomplete out of
control brain we got now and endorsed by
science a way to tap into the brain and
make the chains you love you
beloved's do not only love bring non
sentimental functionality effectivity to
work them and get it done it's beautiful
man what do you think people most
misunderstand about you yeah I look like
a crazy [ __ ] but I am a crazy
[ __ ]
the thing is I'm gonna also change the
world and that is normally a he is a
crazy [ __ ] yes I am but I'm
changing the world
so do understand that all right so we
got to wrap this up here in a minute
but I want to I want I want to know what
you mean when you say nature can be
merciless but righteous which is
something you say often mmm-hmm yeah if
you go if you find yourself on a
climbing without gear there is no mercy
there you have to think your Gramps away
otherwise you die you you become blocked
or when you are under the eyes you gotta
find a way out of there and not go into
panic and paranoia because it kills you
it gets you out of control or a there on
Mount Everest in in a wideout
you gotta find a way otherwise you
freeze to death and many other
situations have lots to me yeah nature
is merciless
but at that moment you always have a a
gap wherein you can find a way out
trust deeply trust and be confident that
you don't need fear because you have the
control over your mind even in the in
the in the greatest of despair and a
darkest
of your moments to get out because the
light is the love and the love is the
universe and we got him the mind truly
is the final frontier yes yes and you
are you are an astronaut into the deep
recesses of this uncharted geography of
consciousness and the brain and I
commend you for that man this is this is
uh this is worthy work for your life and
you're doing much good for Humanity and
it's greatly appreciated what's cool is
that it's really been done outside of
any mainstream media I mean you had you
did the vice documentary and you get
covered in various places but it's
YouTube and podcasts and and really this
new form of media that is really helping
to spread your word and I think it
speaks to the power of how of how
storytelling has shifted and the way
that we receive it as a culture and I
wish you well thank you want to after
this will you go out and teach me like a
quick breath practice yes we can share
with people nice so for people that are
listening to this we'll put that up on
YouTube and and everybody can get it get
a little taste of whim and the work that
he does I know you guys are on tour
right now and you're teaching workshops
do you want to let people know where
they can find out about that and come
and see you and and take one of these
workshops and yes blow there mom thank
you thank you for the space
it's the wim hof that's my name method
wasn't me who made that up it was
somebody else but nice wim HOF method
dot-com
we will be in New York Miami next month
and San Francisco Los Angeles there
right now we go to Vancouver and just be
there because when I talk to a crowd to
people then it's always new I just
relate to what I feel I trust my feeling
and to come up with the
with the right answers with the right
understanding clarity and that's because
we are the tribe we are like a driver so
we have to come up with the existence
and blockages of energy at that moment
and for that a live experience is a live
experience that is nice that's good
know one thing we found the gateway into
the deepest of the brain and the power
of the mind is the future and we are in
control of that and with that comes the
absolute guarantee of happiness strength
and health I would not want anything
more love for you and for me and for
everybody my friend yes uh cool you
should be doing how come you don't have
like a TV show are you doing a
documentary like would you have any of
that kind of thing in the works yeah yes
uh
maybe my daughter know said that yeah
what do you say yeah I do documentaries
coming no TV show all right so we have
would be great TV show yeah why don't we
Charlotte you want to do that oh yeah TV
show with you yeah all right become rich
man and play your role there you go all
right Deku come back and talk to me
again much love brother
yeah Matisse Glantz consciousness yes
all good it's all there yep all right
buddy
[Music]
you